"The situation is under control" – a reassuring
message from the Congolese government, after
it mistakenly announced on Saturday that there
had been another volcanic eruption near the
eastern city of Goma.
The false alarm came only a week after Mount
Nyiragongo roared back to life – forcing
hundreds of thousands of people to flee the
area.
Now, some are braving the return home.
More than a thousand volcano refugees left
a camp in Rwanda on Saturday and queued at
the border of the Democratic Republic of Congo
in the hope of a return to normal life once
more.
But slowly returning to the city of Goma,
many people no longer have anywhere to call
home – after the Nyiragongo volcano roared
back to life several days ago.
Africa's most active volcano saw terrified
people flee the Congolese city as rivers of
lava killed dozens of people and left tens
of thousands homeless.
Fears that Mount Nyiragongo could become active
again days after the initial eruption sparked
a mass evacuation of more than half of Goma's
neighborhoods.
The metropolis is home to about 1.5 million.
People have sought shelter wherever they could,
including school classrooms.
Many said they were struggling to find enough
food and water as the United Nations called
for aid and warned about the risk of cholera.
However, not everyone fled the area - frontline
healthcare workers stayed behind to care for
their patients.
This new mother was in labour when the alarm
was sounded once more.
"We took an oath to remain by our patients'
side.
We couldn't run away and follow those who
fled, we had to first observe and see who
among the population would be the last to
leave and see if we were going to flee if
the situation got more complicated."
The natural beauty of Mount Nyiragongo betrays
its volatile nature – leaving thousands
to pick up the pieces and rebuild their lives.